Things can get pretty serious over at the
SCP Foundation.
From world-ending eldritch beings like The
Scarlet King to massive reptiles filled with
hate, it can be difficult to find things to
smile about while staring into the face of
unknowable horror day after day.
I don't know about all of you, but I could
use a break from the neck-snapping sculptures
and old men climbing out of walls.
So welcome guys, gals, and lovers of laughter!
Come on down and take a seat!
It's open mic night here at the SCP Foundation,
and we're hoping to give you a show that won't
make you want to take amnestics!
Welcome to the SCP Explained Comedy Night!
Some of the funniest anomalies ever contained
by the Foundation are lined up backstage and
ready to show you their stuff, so without
further ado let's get this show on the road
and find out which SCPs will make you bust
a gut, and which ones will be taking a Bad
Joke Tomato to the head.
We've got a whole bucket of these babies ready
to go in the wings, and remember: they can
reach speeds of over 100 miles per hour, so...bring
your A-game, everybody.
First up coming to the stage, fresh off a
morale-boosting tour around Site-19, you know
him, you love him, he's the sweetest silliest
slimiest guy around: It's SCP-999, the Tickle
Monster!
Just because he can't say anything funny,
or anything at all aside from those adorable
little chirping sounds he makes, that doesn't
mean he can't get a good giggle or two out
of you!
Sure, some folks out there might say "oh,
tickling doesn't count!"
but those people just hate fun.
He may not be a comedian in the strictest
sense of the word, but you just can't keep
a straight face when this guy comes around.
You've gotta break out in a smile.
Just look at him go!
Sliming all over the place, doing his thing.
Love that for you!
Oh, and there he goes, he found a chocolate
bar.
Go ahead, buddy!
You've earned it!
Do you like prop comedy?
Juggling?
Do you think it's the funniest thing in the
world to watch your buddy stuff as many marshmallows
as humanly possible into his mouth and try
not to choke?
Then I've got some great news for you, up
next we've got the one, the only, SCP-2094.
That's right, folks...It's Motormouth!
This guy is an extremely proficient juggler
and circus performer, but that's not all.
He can fit anything, and I mean anything,
into his mouth.
Seriously, he's literally capable of stretching
his mouth up to two meters in any direction
with feeling any pain.
Talk about jaw-dropping.
And inside?
He's got an extradimensional organ made of
seriously stretchy tissue.
I heard some of you laugh when I said extradimensional
organ, that's the spirit!
Watch as he swallows a luxury sports car,
that ugly sweater your grandma got you for
Christmas, that overstuffed chair your ex-wife
left behind!
All that, and he's still got room in his mouth
for jokes, too.
We've all heard about the various things this
next guy isn't allowed to do at the Foundation.
From using anomalies to alter the outcome
of reality tv shows to pranking new staff
members, his antics are as legendary as the
amulet around his neck that holds his consciousness
and pure essence!
It's Dr. Jack Bright!
This immortal trickster has a taste for mischief,
even when it gets in the way of his colleagues'
important work.
We've all been there, sometimes a goof is
just too good to go un-goofed!
So what if it threatens to destroy the fabric
of reality or unleash a monster with an insatiable
lust for blood?
We'll all learn to laugh about it later.
Dr. Bright isn't the best coworker, but he's
always the life of the party and he really
knows how to command the attention of the
room.
Just one thing, if he tosses that amulet at
you, don't catch it.
Unless you think complete and total brain
death as your mind and all your memories are
taken over by his sounds like a great way
to end your evening.
Sometimes the best comedy is the simplest.
Let's throw it back to the days of America's
Funniest Home Videos, when households all
over the country were guffawing at the sight
of home movies of people getting knocked into
pools, hit in the head with plastic bats,
and falling over in a variety of different
ways.
It might sound terrible to say, but we can
all agree: people falling over can be pretty
hilarious.
But what about a robot falling over?
What if that robot also was convinced that
it could destroy you, or anything else it
encountered, in hand-to-hand combat?
Pretty ridiculous, right?
Don't worry, it's not too good to be true.
Please give a round of applause for SCP-1370,
Pesterbot.
"I am RoboLord the Destructor, ender of all
life!
Tremble before me!"
That's right, buddy, you tell 'em.
Careful, there's a mic cord on the ground
there, don't--
Aaaand, he's down.
Like a turtle flipped onto its back.
Can someone flip Pesterbot back over?
Thanks, Brian.
You're my rock.
Give it up for Sound Engineer Brian, everybody!
And for Pesterbot, of course.
He's kind of a one-trick pony, but man that
trick never gets old.
Trying so hard to be intimidating, and then
bam.
Down like a ton of bricks.
I almost feel bad for the guy.
Almost, but not quite.
You'll get 'em next time, pal.
Up next, we've got a guy who proves that when
it comes to leading an adventurous life, and
having the best party stories of all time,
size doesn't matter!
Get your mind out of the gutter, I'm talking
about SCP-1867, Lord Blackwood.
Don't just this book by its cover, this little
sea slug defies expectations at every turn.
If you believe a word that comes out of his
mouth, that is.
I'll be honest, a lot of what's funny about
Lord Bloodwood is unintentional, sorry M'lord.
But you kind of can't beat the feeling of
hearing a sea slug say "Tallo ho!" or tell
you about the time he personally went head
to head with SCP-682 on a hunting expedition.
That's not to discount his ability to be funny
on purpose, either.
If you prefer sophisticated wit over slapstick,
you can share some chuckles with Lord Blackwood
over a glass of his finest whiskey.
Can slugs have whiskey?
Apparently, this one can.
"CACK!"
Excuse me, I'm in the middle of something.
Fine, okay, jeez, you can have your turn.
That very insistent voice calling to me from
offstage is none other than SCP-2337, Dr.
Spanko!
Doctor of what exactly, I'm not sure.
This sapient male corn crake will talk your
ear off if you let him, sometimes literally.
Not that you'll be able to understand a word
he says, unless you're familiar with the particularly
silly dialect of English he seems to speak.
Say hello, Doctor!
"It me!
Cack!"
Make sure you keep your distance, as this
bird's bark is also his bite.
By which I mean, his vocalizations are extremely
loud, and can cause serious damage to your
ears if you're not careful.
But what a way for your hearing to go out,
listening to this weird little bird talk,
shout, or even yodel.
Don't even think about heckling him, either.
He might scratch your eyes out.
Just toss some gummy worms up on the stage,
and no one gets hurt.
Speaking of getting hurt, do you like practical
jokes?
How about television?
How about mixing the two together?
No need to answer, because our next guest
is already here whether you like it or not.
Have you ever like laugh you come laugh and
have all the fun and laugh!
Starring all your favorite laugh so ever and
always make go to your life!
Ahem.
Sorry, I don't know what that was, something
came over me all of a sudden.
Anyway, here's SCP-2030, everyone's favorite
anomalous tv show, Laugh!
Is!
Fun!
With your host, Laughy McLaugherson!
If you've never seen the show before, then
well, you're in for a hell of a treat.
It's a hidden camera comedy, a bit like Punk'd
if you can remember that one, catching everyday
people in wild, wacky situations, like meeting
a talking dog, being shoved through a mail
slot, or having their hair suddenly catch
on fire!
It's a riot!
Seriously, sometimes there's an actual riot,
I watched someone get torn to pieces!
Ha!
There's only one thing this show and its mysterious,
faceless host want in this world: To make
you laugh!
Because why?
Laugh!
Is!
Fun!
Don't look up the people who appear on the
show to find out what happened to them after
their appearance, though.
You might not like what you find.
Phew, took things out on a bit of a dark note
there.
Let's lighten it up with something beautiful
huh?
How about that?
Does that sound good to you guys?
I know it sounds good to me.
Great!
Because here comes the most beautiful person
you've ever seen.
SCP-056, A Beautiful Person!
Some critics out there will say that a person
can't have both looks and personality, that
there's no way someone this supernaturally
gorgeous could also be funny.
But they'd be wrong.
See, this anomalous individual changes to
suit the preferences of their environment,
becoming whatever would be superior to the
person they're currently with.
They've transformed into a large, beautiful
labrador in the presence of a dog, a woman
looking like Scarlett Johansson around a group
of young female staff, a gorgeous and brilliant
female doctor in a white lab coat, an impossibly
strong male bodybuilder, a woman with cat
ears and a tail in the presence of one researcher
with an anime habit, and more.
So, if you put them in a comedy club, they'll
be the funniest one in the room by default.
They can't help it!
So if the hottest thing in the world to you
is a sense of humor?
Get ready to crack up.
But I hope you've got a thick skin, because
SCP-056 has a real nasty attitude, and tends
to prefer insult comedy.
Don't let it get you down, though.
They're that rude to everybody.
It's hard to be the best at everything in
the world without your ego inflating to the
size of the empire state building.
Would you look at that?
We've got a second celebrity guest in the
room tonight, another performer you might
recognize from inside your TV!
I hope you don't think clowns are scary, because
it's time for SCP-993, Bobble the Clown!
Bobble the Clown is the start of his titular
television show, which features him learning
all about different new skills!
Of course, if you're over the age of 10, you
might not have seen the show at all, since
folks above that age cutoff become unconscious
upon viewing an episode.
So if you've missed it, I'll get you up to
speed: Bobble teaches all kinds of useful
skills for everyday life, such as...let me
check my notes here...Cooking and preparing
human flesh, lighting fires without drawing
attention from the police, silently stalking
strangers through the streets, extracting
information through torture, and... breaching
SCP containment?!
I'm sorry, this appears to be some kind of
mistake.
Security?
Can I get security please?
Get this clown out of here!
I'm so sorry about that, everyone.
Great comedy should push the envelope and
bend the rules, but there are some lines that
just shouldn't be crossed.
Like cannibalism, and breaking security protocols.
If you'll forgive the interruption, we'll
get on with the show.
Do I have anyone from Boston in the crowd
tonight, let me hear some noise for Boston!
Do I have any fish in the crowd tonight?
Put your fins together!
Great, great, well you Bostonites and fish
alike will love our next kooky character coming
to the mic, it's one of Dr. Wondertainment's
famous Littler Misters, SCP-527, Mr. Fish!
Love the top hat, buddy!
Looking dapper, looking good.
Now, Mr. Fish doesn't do any tricks, no breathing
underwater or anything flashy like that.
He doesn't need to!
Just being himself is plenty.
"Hey, what are you lookin' at?
You think this is some kinda joke?
I'm just a guy with a fish head, okay?"
Do you know any jokes, though?
"Sure, fine.
Uh.
What do you call a fish with no eyes?"
I don't know, what do you call a fish with
no eyes?
"A fsssssh.
Take care everybody, tip your waitress, I'm
going home."
Mr. Fish, everybody!
Great guy, great guy.
You'll be over the moon for the next anomaly
on our lineup.
He's not crazy, he's just a little bit spacey...
I want you to give a warm, interstellar welcome
to SCP-1233, The Lunatic!
This guy came a long way for our show, from
outside the Earth's atmosphere in fact.
SCP-1233 is a humanoid entity resembling a
person in an EMU-type spacesuit, complete
with visor and propulsion jetpack.
It's no ordinary suit, either, it's resistant
to explosions and x-ray scans, as well as
being totally bullet-proof.
But what's funny about all that, you ask?
Some say that laughter is the sound of surprise,
and this guy is nothing if not surprising.
He arrives on earth by falling out of the
sky before crashing into the ground like a
meteorite, and immediately climbs out of the
hole and starts looking for volunteers to
join him in the fight against the Moon Monsters.
Now, the war is no laughing matter, but how
can you keep a straight face when he's mistaking
a cookie for a parakeet or trying to use a
dog to buy more dogs?
That's star quality, right there.
Pun intended.
Don't even think about it though, tomatoes,
I'm in charge up here.
Up next, we have me!
I mean, me.
Me.
For crying out loud, I'm SCP-426, and I'm
coming to the stage!
I am an ordinary toaster that does everything
a toaster is supposed to do, mainly, make
bread into toast.
But when a human being talks about me, they're
unable to describe me in the third person.
No matter how hard they try, they'll find
themselves talking about me in the first person
instead.
If they're around me for too long, usually
around two months or more, they will begin
to see themselves as a toaster, and try to
plug themselves into the wall and toast bread.
Not me, me.
I mean, me.
I'm not a toaster, I am!
Stop laughing, this isn't funny, get me out
of here.
Not me me, toaster me!
Thank you.
Finally.
That was horrible.
I'm never eating toast again.
Okay, that's a lie, I'll probably have a piece
tomorrow.
Can't resist that crunch!
Anyway, up next is the stuff of legends, someone
who's been in the game for years, and has
the most devoted following I've ever seen.
Put your tentacles together and give it up
for SCP-2662, Cthulu!
He's a cognitohazardous entity, about four
meters tall with 20 fully functioning tentacles
on his back.
Talk about multitasking.
Cthulu's a nice guy, no ego to speak of, but
he's got a bit of an interesting effect on
people.
Let's call him...an acquired taste.
After someone has been exposed to him for
a prolonged period of time, around 6 months
or longer, they'll become increasingly compelled
to do whatever he wants and become a sort
of servant.
So, to get an honest reaction, he'll only
practice his standup material on people he's
known for less than 6 months.
I mentioned his fan-base before, and I wasn't
kidding when I said they're devoted.
Without meaning, or even wanting to, SCP-2662
is able to spontaneously generate religious
followings about once a month.
You can't pick your fans, no matter how hard
you try.
And believe me, he's tried.
Everybody wants to be a celebrity until that
fame comes with strangers trying to break
you out of Foundation containment and perform
dark arcane rituals with you.
Poor guy.
He just wants to be recognized for his sense
of humor, rather than his incomprehensible
ancient powers and status as an elder god.
You know what we haven't had much of yet today?
Animal acts.
That seems like a real missed opportunity
for those of us who find nothing in the world
funnier than an animal doing something you
wouldn't normally see.
A monkey making a phone call?
Incredible.
Who's he calling?
The CEO of bananas?
Or how about a cat in a little business suit?
Hilarious, and adorable.
Well, I hope you're not an arachnophobe, because
up next we've got SCP-1006, the Communist
Spiders!
These little guys are incredibly impressive,
consisting of an organized collective of an
unknown spider species, all of whom have somehow
achieved sapience and organized themselves
into a tiny functioning government.
They've used their webs to spell out propaganda
messages and illustrate portraits of people's
faces, as well as developing simple tools.
When given alternate methods of communication
that don't come out of their butts, such as
ink and poster paper, the spiders are happy
to make their thoughts known to humans.
Don't get too comfortable with them, they're
not especially fond of what the Bourgeois
Humanoids have done with the outside world.
Politically active spiders are pretty great
conceptually, but don't let them hear you
laughing.
If you get on their bad side, you might end
up like the skeletal human remains found in
part of their central web.
Can we get these guys out of here, actually?
Their little legs are giving me the creeps.
Speaking of the creeps, horror and comedy
are often two sides of the same coin.
Both rely on the subversion of expectations,
building up tension before releasing it, either
with a scream or a bout of laughter!
Just look at horror-comedy as a genre, or
successful comedians who've pivoted to the
world of scares and shrieks.
Or for the opposite side, look at some of
the horror movies that once terrified audiences
in the days before technicolor.
Absurd-looking plastic skeletons flopping
around while an actress screams unconvincingly
and runs in slow-motion, giant cardboard ants
demolishing cities.
Sometimes, something intended to be very scary
is actually just extremely funny.
That brings us to SCP-2006, Too Spooky!
When in its default state, SCP-2006 is a spherical
entity about 50 centimeters in diameter.
However, it's rarely in this shape for long.
All that this thing wants in the world is
to scare humans, and it will shift to whatever
shape it thinks will help it accomplish that
goal.
Unfortunately for 2006, and fortunately for
humanity, its sense of what is scary is not
especially well-formed.
It tends to model itself after characters
from just the type of B movies I was talking
about.
Its current favorite shape is that of the
titular villain from the 1953 film, "Robot
Monster."
It's a nice effort, it really is, but when
that big goofy gorilla suit with a space helmet
on top comes jumping at you, it's one of the
funniest things I've ever seen.
Do me a favor though, if it tries to scare
you, humor it, will you?
Just play along.
It's the polite thing to do.
Up next, like many of the people you see hitting
up comedy open mics, this next guest has a
day job he won't be quitting any time soon.
It's SCP-2598, the traveling moth salesman!
You may have some trouble seeing him from
the audience, but he's a large yellow underwing
moth wearing a tiny little helmet.
He is able to communicate using morse code,
so if you're not familiar with it, you'll
need someone to translate what he says for
you.
No matter what you're talking about, SCP-2598
will always try to redirect the conversation
toward a specialized helmet for moths, also
known as Moth Helm, available for three easy
payments of 19.99.
I'd tell you more about it, but unless they
offer to sponsor the show I don't think I
should give them any more free advertising.
Wait a second, my guest is flying away…
Hey, where are you going?
Oh, I see, moths gotta moth.
Well, they're giving me the light, so that's
my time everybody!
Now I've gotta get to my next gig.
I'm hosting Dr. Bright's annual karaoke contest,
and I just know he's going to do all of Bohemian
Rhapsody again.
So, I'm gonna get out of here, but first:
Which SCP do you think is the funniest?
Let us know in the comments below, and maybe
we'll give them some more time in the spotlight!
Next, go check out "SCP Dating Game" and "Top
14 Friendliest SCPs" for more fun with SCP
Compilations!